hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
gestern einen vorteil ein video
hochgeladen was richtig gut bei euch
ankam
naja also zumindest hat es 10.000
kommentare bekommen oder hab ich mir die
kommentare heute noch so angeschaut und
habe mir dann wirklich einfach gedacht
eigentlich darf ich euch ein paar
kommentare gar nicht vorenthalten
du hast alles falsch gemacht das geht
eigentlich gar nicht na ja also ich habe
es ja irgendwie geschafft also geht es
ja ich war selbst bei meiner ersten
runde schon viel viel viel viel viel
besser
da kann ich nur sagen cool freut mich
immer als die polizei erlaubt komme ich
jetzt im knast ich fange an zu weinen
wenn ich abonniert bekommt fünf
abonnenten zurück ein fake er ist
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen was
schreibst du typ denn so rum tut mir
leid liebe kommentarschreiber in meinem
nächsten video halte ich einfach die
ganze zeit meine fresse um
ich finds nah ist dass du dich hier
direkt mit einem adjektiv beschreibst du
bist schlecht ihnen vorbei ich bin level
50 und habe battle pass und habe den
letzten menschen und habe 100 59 siege
alte hässlich man ich hoffe ich werde es
mal so weit bringen wie du du kannst gar
nichts kick mal fordert bei den puhdys
und wen du kontakte hat fragt sie ob sie
dir helfen was die haben die klicks auch
nicht gereicht ja komm ja du hast recht
ich habe mich vor dem video gedacht ok
kommen luca hörst jetzt auch mit youtube
reichen die die klicks aber nee hab ich
noch was hochgeladen tut mir leid
passiert nie wieder mach eins nach video
du blöde kuh 5000 mal habe ich das
gesagt tut mir leid muss ich ganz
ehrlich gesagt an der stelle hier sagen
wenn du es noch 5000 mal häufiger sagst
dann wird das video kommen ich spiele es
und ich bin viel besser als du da
spielt vor ort eine sehr oft augenkrebs
es tut mir sehr leid dass du unser
seiner krankheit leidet aber es gibt
möglichkeiten das zu besiegen spiel das
nicht oft okay ich hör auf schau dir
tutorials anfang an vielen der hashtag
luca punkt shop.de
ja das werde ich tun können mal alle
youtuber aufhören denn vorne zu spielen
ja ok lea und wenn du sagst dann werden
alle auch luca nein du bist nicht der
beste spieler du bist der schlechteste
dass das das macht keinen sinn weil in
meinem video habe ich doch extra gesagt
freunde ihr wisst ich bin der beste
fortnight spieler aller zeiten also wie
blöd bist du das ich habe extra gesagt
du bist einfach so schlecht ja das war
richtig lustig blutleer gleich der fuß
see machst du so dumm oder bist du
wirklich so dumm der tut mir leid muss
ich sagen bin ich leider wirklich so
dumm deine frisur scheiße du bist
scheiße hofmann luca das nächste mal
hoffen dass mike tyson dort wohnt was
hatten mike heißen jetzt damit zu tun
dass tut so weh wenn man sieht dass
jemand ne kiste vergisst ich finde es
tut weh wenn jemand das mit einer nicht
von dem das mit zwei s unterscheiden
kann
katja falscher kanal spiel das nie
wieder die amateure alter hat er das
gerade wirklich geschrieben
amateur liga bitte schreib einfach nie
wieder den namen links sind die von
deinen gruppen kamerad weil du warst in
der timo die ok lade es nochmal hoch
christian ich weiß nicht was christian
jetzt damit zu tun hat aber okay dann
lade ich noch mal hoch omg gratis nackt
bilder gibt es hier
du wirst verdammt noch mal geblockt
jetzt so ein schnell kicker was ist
schnell kicker mach bitte wer gaming
naja also wenn ich mir die kommentare so
angucke dann glaube ich eher nicht
und mal ganz kurz real talk freunde ich
weiß nicht ob die ganzen leute die jetzt
irgendwie über die letzten monate hier
habt ihr ein krasses wachstum hier
irgendwie auf dem kanal ich glaube die
ganze leute die jetzt neu dazu gekommen
sind über die letzten monate wissen
nicht so ganz was ich früher für gaming
videos gemacht habt heute eine ganz
kurze aufklärung ich bin der
schlechteste gamer der welt mir macht
aber trotzdem spaß also nur weil ihr
sagt dass ihr in euren ersten spiel mit
elf jahren und mit einer gebrochenen
hand doppelt so viele kids gemacht habe
wie ich das wären immer noch nur weil
ich keinen hehl gemacht habe das
tangiert mich eigentlich er gar nicht
ich mir macht fordert spaß und deswegen
wird die tage noch ein zweiter fahrt
kommen hat ihr gehen welche tipps habt
für mich im vorteil
dann schreibt mir das gerne unter die
kommentare wollt ihr eventuell dass ich
demnächst mal ein bisschen mehr game ich
mache also vielleicht wieder ein paar
spiele wie früher zb die sesamstraße mal
gespielt weil sie gaming ideen habt ihr
jetzt irgendwelche browsergames irgend
etwas lustiges witziges vielleicht
irgendwelche kinderspiele in welche
mädchen spieler weiß ich irgendwas was
nicht cool ist die spiellust die
schneiden kann schreibt scanner und in
die kommentare und jetzt würde ich
einfach sagen welches halten wird